Montessori education is based on the
principles developed by Maria Montessori
who opened her first school for children
of low-income workers in an apartment
building in Rome in 1907 the school was
called Casa de bambini home for children
this first casa was furnished with a
teacher's table a stove a blackboard
some chairs group tables for the
children and a cabinet filled with
materials that Montessori developed in
her earlier career when she researched
how to teach kids who experienced some
form of mental disability Maria
Montessori created the materials after
she realized that students seemed to
understand complex concepts better when
they engaged all their senses activities
at this first school included personal
care such as dressing and undressing
care of the environment like sweeping
dusting and gardening otherwise they
were free to move around and play with
the materials Montessori did not teach
herself but instead oversaw the
classroom work of her teachers
Montessori observed that children showed
episodes of deep concentration and
multiple repetitions of the same
activity given free choice kids showed
more interest in practical activities
and the materials than normal toys
sweets or other rewards over time
spontaneous self discipline emerged
Montessori concluded that working
independently children seemed to reach
new levels of autonomy and became self
motivated learners she began to see the
role of the teacher as a facilitator of
young human beings who are free to move
and act within the limits of a prepared
environment the goal to grow children to
become independent and responsible
adults who share a love for learning
soon after Montessori herself and her
ideas started traveling the world to
inspired progressive thinkers and
educators from all over the inventors
Alexander Graham Bell and Thomas Edison
became early advocates later alumni
include Jimmy Wales from Wikipedia
author Gabriel Garcia Marquez
as well as the to Google founders Larry
Page and Sergey Brin today the term
montessori stands more for a method than
a school itself the fact that it can be
used freely by anyone led to a great
variation of schools educators all over
the world borrow Montessori name
insights and materials to organize
kindergartens Elementary School's
special needs programs or even full
twelve-year curriculums some parents use
it for homeschooling the following
characteristics are shared among most
programs students are free to choose
what to learn open classrooms that allow
free movement use of specialized
Montessori materials mixed age classes
from zero to three three to six or six
to twelve so children can learn from
each other
uninterrupted blocks of study time
usually three hours no grading or
homework and a trained teacher Maria
Montessori once famously said never help
a child with a task at which he feels he
can succeed what are your thoughts on
Montessori please share your opinions in
the comments below